there's also the right values you've
also got to know how to pick the right
men and right now social media has a lot
of women confused thinking that they
need the guy with the most amount of
likes who wears the latest trainers who
has the biggest chain and you're passing
over decent guys and so that that's why
I'm saying again you're being misled
because your Youth and your beauty right
now your internet right now is you are
your Peak this is this is when you
should really be gunning for that guy
this is the time These Guys these older
women are saying oh yeah chill you know
it's a journey you know look at the
woman who are telling you that and tell
me if they're a successful woman in
happy relationships